[Music]
all right here's the boys this is uh New
Kids on the
[Music]
blog
got first time was a great time second
time was a blast third time I fell in
love now I hope it last I can see it in
your walk what you talking about tell
when you talk what you talk about see it
in everything you do
even you got
the hey
baby love the way you turn me on you you
you you got to R
up
baby you're the reason why I sing the
song Hey Hey I said all that I needed
was you
oh girl you're so
right and all that I wanted was you you
made all my dreams come to come and
[Music]
say
right got
the
right first kiss was sweet kiss second
kiss had a
Twist and your kiss I don't want to miss
see it in your walk and it when you talk
see it in everything you do even in your
you
got
baby love the way you turn me on you got
the right St
baby
baby you're the reason why I sing this
song Come On said all that I need it was
you oh girl you're so
right and all that I wanted was you you
made
all all my dreams come say
oh come
on say oh oh oh tell me what you got
right you
got yes you
do
goty the right you got
it got
it got the
[Music]
right yeah got it
yeah
boys that was good this is a very good
sound for you guys doing something like
this we needed an idea for the next tour
so now do
this